hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
make your research count generate
reproducible results with recombinant
antibodies
i am jennifer woods and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and
brought to you by miltoni biotech to
learn more about our sponsor
visit miltonibbiotech.com we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education
credits window i'd like to now welcome
our speaker
dr ermey roy global product manager
for flow cytometry reagents dr roy you
may now begin your presentation
hello everyone thank you for joining us
today
we will be discussing how recombinant
antibodies can
enhance your research reproducibility
to those of you who are not familiar
with melting a biotech
i have this short summary here
miltoniotk was founded in 1989 and over
the last 30 years we have
grown significantly and our pioneering
technologies have constantly been
supporting research works which you can
see from more than 46 000 scientific
citations
our continuously growing product
portfolio ranges from basic research to
clinical applications
and ensure true translation
for today's presentation i have the
following agenda
i will discuss about reproducibility
crisis
and pitfalls and why antibody quality
and validation is important
then i will introduce you to our
recombinant antibodies and show
how they can improve quality of research
i will highlight the importance of
antibody validation for research
and how here at miltonia biotech we
support you with that
and i will sum up with some final
consideration and summary at the end
so to start with the first point
in the past years there is a growing
concern within the scientific community
that many research results are not
reproducible
in 2015 a study published in plos
biology showed around 50
of the preclinical research spent in the
u.s
are basically wasted due to
irreproducible results
and they have categorized the
contributors of such irreproducible data
and biological reasons
were shown to be one of the biggest
culprits among the others
when talking about antibodies and
that they are considered as one of the
key variable that attribute to the
reproducibility crisis
i would like to show you some examples
here
in 2008 in human protein at last project
found that less than 50 of the
commercially available antibodies
recognized
their specific targets which means the
rest
were actually unspecific and in 2009
in dr david dream's lab was unable to
continue their
cancer biomarker study due to antibody
lot specific ear producibility
followed by in 2012 amgen tried to redo
some
previously published preclinical
research studies and only could
reproduce
six out of 53 studies so all these
examples led to a very uh strong debate
in the following years
about the antibody related research
reproducibility and transferring
reporting
of this of their use
and later on several reports came up
where need for better technology were
discussed among scientists companies
as well as organizations like nih
and recombinant antibodies were
discussed to be
used to tackle such a situation
so what are exactly the facts that
affect the antibody performance in flow
cytometry and results in
a puzzled research outcome here i am
showing you
several important factors that are
[Music]
including the unspecific binding of
antibodies
resulting in background noise lot
specific variability
insufficient sensitivity as well as poor
characterization and lack of
reason information these are also very
important factors
that affect the performance using
reagent without
knowing how they will perform under
specific condition condition
as well as experimental protocol may
also contribute to data variability
and finally use of reason from different
source
means that you have to use different
control
and without such proper control you
cannot ensure the performance of your
data
so what can we do to overcome all these
kind of
factors that affect the reproducibility
crisis and that are originated from
antibodies
we believe there are three solutions
use of advanced technology to create
better reagent
proper validation of the reagents and
thorough documentation that can be
followed by the fellow researchers
we at milton biotech are trying our best
to support you with reagents
produced using the best technology
and together with the support from the
scientists in the validation and
documentation effort
we can battle with the reproducibility
problem
with the advanced technology
this is where i would like to introduce
you to the recombinant antibody
technology
at the moment there are three prominent
categories for antibody generation
polyclonal antibody hybridoma derived
and
recombinantly derived monoclonal
antibodies
and with this chart i am showing you a
very summarized way of differences among
these three categories
so polyclonal antibodies are basically a
mixture of heterogeneous antibodies that
recognizes several epitopes
resulting in a stronger signal which is
obviously important for certain
application
these are purified from serum of
immunized animals and offer
very low lot to lot consistency and
therefore it's not really a very
good suitable um antibody for flow
cytometry
on the other hand monoclonal antibody
derived from hybridoma
are actually mixture of homogeneous
antibodies
that recognize only one epitope thereby
ensure higher specificity
these are purified from single clone of
immortal hybridoma cell lines
and also offers lot to load consistency
therefore it's a good choice for um
flow cytometry application finally the
recombinant
monoclonal antibody their genetically
defined antibody i will show you later a
little bit more in detail
this means that they are defined on
their dna level and recognizes also only
one epitope with their highest
specificity
and genetically engineered antibody
together with a
defined expression production system
ensure the highest slot rollout
consistency
and thereby also
the best fitted antibody for flow
cytometry application
so um let's have a closer manufacturing
process of hybridoma
versus recombinant antibodies
hybridoma clones are generated from
fusion protein
from an antibody produced in b cell and
immortal myeloma cell they are not pure
because they contain
lychen produced by myeloma cells
which are also b cells here and you can
see with the green
with this green light chain contaminant
and also in case this kind of cell line
are
cultured over long term with many
passages
this can lead to spontaneous mutation
and that
results in antibody clone which is
different
than your expectation further
contamination can also happen
coming from the culture media which are
also
basically from serum and then led to
some um
immunoglobulin impurity in your
resulting
antibody therefore all this leads to a
lot to load variability as well as big
decrease in the purity of the product
recombinant antibody on the other hand
are genetically engineered
they have a defined dna sequence which
is inserted into a mammalian cells
that are programmed to express the
product of this particular dna sequence
since they are not derived from b cell
and also cultured in a
defined condition the contaminants that
you have seen in the hybridoma clone
scenario
is not there for the recombinant
antibodies these allow
higher base consistency and purity and
additional benefit
include the ability to engineer these
antibodies with the highest
flexibility and this i will show you
later in the slides that how miltonii
biotech
took the advantage of this technology of
recombinant antibody
to generate high quality product
now since 2012 we are offering
our recombinant recombinantly generated
antibody that we call reaffinity
antibody
and this antibody offers superior
technology as well as
high quality production and in the next
slide i will shortly outline some of the
key benefits that comes along with this
technology so when we're talking about
the technology itself
and here you you can see a model of our
reaffinity antibody here we took the
advantage of
the genetic engineering to generate this
antibody
which contained the antibody variable
region
here depicted as orange
and this is um derived from hybridoma
clone
which has validated application for flow
cytometry so they are very specific
then you have the the backbone which
here in
uh purple are deriving from
the constant region of human igd-1
so all our antibody basically contains
the same igg-1 backbone
finally we have used the fc region
of the backbone we have done some
mutation there to abolish their
binding to fc gamma receptor and i will
show you later what are the benefits
with this kind of mutation so first of
all
as highlighted earlier that recombinant
antibody generation
results in highest purity here is an
example of mass
by spectrometry data where you can
see clearly that recombinantly generated
antibody
shows um highly pure um
antibody compared to your um
hybridomaclone where you have this um
this pink star that is showing some
contaminating light chain
and in in this way we are a
really high highest purity product
now when i told you about this mutation
about the
fc region here is uh some
data where you can see that
there are five different fc gamma
receptors
which were tested comparing our
re-affinity antibody in light um blue
and the
monoclonal hybrid of antibodies yeah
dark purple and you can see that um
our hybrid compared to hybrid antibody
our
infinity antibody showed very um slight
uh or significantly lower binding to
this
unspecific fc gamma receptor and now why
should you care about this kind of
binding to fc
all these fc gamma receptors and this i
will show you
with a customer provided data thanks to
our customer um who has shared with us
this data
and here you can see in the plot on the
left hand side
where you can see from hybridoma clone
um
which offers the um which shows this
unspecific binding
marked with this um red symbol
and you can see that it's not consistent
in all hybridoma clones so one
hybridomacron one did not show this
binding um unspecific binding compared
to hypodermal clone two
and without any scr block on the other
hand in the
affinity clone you don't see this
background so of course
you can use the scr block reagent which
are commonly used in the field to get
rid of this
kind of unspecific binding but this
does not ensure the perfect scenario
because sometimes
here in this case you see that you could
not get rid of it
completely and this obviously includes
unnecessary additional
experimental variability that comes
along with the
fcr block regent itself so if possible
it's better to avoid such um
such an experimental condition
finally um i i showed you that our um
recommend an antibody contains
universal human igg-1 backbone and what
is the benefit with that
ideally when you use hybridomaterial
monoclonal antibody
they probably were generated with many
different uh
background for example mouse igm
igg2 and so red iv ig1 or so on
this means for every individual
isotype you have to make a proper
control for them
so this leads to a complex experimental
planning and inventory management
compared to that in case of reaffinity
antibody due to the fact that we have a
universal backbone you only need in such
a case
you only need one isotope control and
that allows you to perform a
straightforward experimental planning
as well as inventory management
now in the next part i would like to
briefly touch
about the high quality production of our
final antibody product
and our production procedure follows
strict steps
to ensure highest quality and throughout
the process the quality
is thoroughly monitored and the relevant
information we also provide to customers
for specific regulated research that is
very important
here is a brief outline of our antibody
purification process
antibody and fluorochrome both um as the
starting material are
generated with strict quality control
and upon the
highly qualified starting material we
perform the coupling
and then we perform thorough
purification step
for the gate to get rid of unbound
antibody as well as unbound
fluorochrome to ensure highly pure
only conjugated antibodies in the final
product
and we also perform functional tests on
primary samples
to test the performance of the antibody
and these we maintain across all the lot
here i must mainta mention that
this also is performed with the
titration
what does this mean that when you have
performed such a lot
uh specific experiment this leads to
product that will perform the same
exactly same in every
antibody lot and with this data set you
can see for cd56
conjugated to different fluorochrome we
have compared two different lot and you
can see their performance is exactly the
same in this histogram
and as i mentioned every lot is tested
and titrated
for optimal performance and thereby we
ensure the high load to load consistency
as well as reduce
your effort to every time perform a
titration experiment for
every lot of antibody
as mentioned earlier you can easily
access
also our additional documentation such
as certificate of analysis
for respective product lot after
purchase
and you can easily download them
directly from our coa tool in the
website
so here since i mentioned since 2012
we have started with this recombinant
antibody
portfolio and over the years we we made
sure that we have
we cover all the in markers and
we are proud to say that we have the
largest portfolio
of recommended antibody at the moment
which are optimized and validated for
flow cytometry which includes more than
1000 clones and also as a final product
our antibodies are conjugated to our um
highly bright
biodice family and all
all together we have more than sixteen
thousand fluorochrome conjugated
products
which are um the specificity uh ranges
from different
cross reactivity from human to rodent as
well as non-human primate
and as i mentioned we cover a lot of
different markers that are cell specific
and also different application like
immune checkpoints
cell signaling cell death and more
markers are covered within our portfolio
just
here quickly to mention that we also
are increasing our portfolio and testing
them beyond flow cytometry
specifically focusing on their
application in imaging as well as mass
cytometry
now the next part of my talk i would
like to emphasize
on antibody validation and our company
effort
on this topic
so several key opinion leader in the
antibody field has discussed and defined
the standard
which are required to achieve highest
quality antibodies
this includes reproducibility
specificity
and sensitivity and our aim
is to use the available tools to
validate
all our antibodies and communicate this
to our customer in a
very transparent manner so in the next
slides i will show you
what are these steps that we are taking
here miltoni biotech to achieve these
validation standards
so i would start with the
reproducibility where in the field it's
often discussed about the lot
performance of the antibody
and here i won't go so much into detail
because this argument for us
being as a company which where we ensure
the highest reproducibility is come
is coming with the benefit of our
affinity antibody technology
so starting from the recombinant
antibody technology
until the manufacturing we can achieve
the highest
reproducibility level by a lot specific
reagent
with all the benefits that i already
mentioned earlier
so you can you can definitely
be sure that our antibody offer you the
highest reproducibility standard
in this regard i would like to go more
detail into the topic of
specificity this is a very important
point
because often there is a lot of research
which cannot be reproduced because the
antibody was not specific enough to the
target antigen
and therefore this is one of the mostly
debated topic in the field
so what we are perform what we are doing
to
ensure the antibody specificity of our
affinity antibodies
so we do several experiments
during the individual product
development we perform suitable counter
staining to verify
that the antibody is actually binding to
the
target population of cell of interest
moreover we perform essays
with advanced technologies such as
crispr cards
to use knockout of target protein as
well as we perform epidural
competition as this i will show you a
little bit more detail later
moreover for specific specificity that
require
additional essays there we also perform
tests like
sir and a knockdown we perform tests
like stimulated cells
over expression of a specific target
protein
as well as we perform experiments like
binding of purified antigen
that are coated in latex bit
now as i said that in the field
the really high quality specificity
tests
are recognized to be validated by an
assays um such as the knockout of target
protein
as well as testing their epitope
recognition
so what are we doing here at milton
about it to to confirm that
so to um to test this um
antibody specificity here
our aim is that we generate cell lines
um where we knock out the
exact protein of interest from the cell
and we compare the end
performance of the antibody um to wild
type
versus knockout and we also display this
data in our website
uh this first data set that you can see
here is
coming from a microscope and um you can
see that in a wild type
um cell line the target antigen
is present so the antibody is showing
very nicely
uh staining here in red and in a
knockout cell
this is completely gone this means that
our
antibody was highly specific for this
target antigen
and we also demonstrate this kind of
data using a flow cytometry
for the red histogram here you see the
red
which is um wild type and then for
knockout is the blue
so the benefit for you here is that you
need less validation
you can trust on this antibody and this
also gives you confidence about the
quality of the antibody
so the second test that we perform is
epitope computation assay
our recombinant antibody clones have
specific name
with ria at the beginning and we are
aware that this might be difficult for
you
to recognize the binding of our react
clone compared to
other known hybridomacron so we perform
tests to monitor where whether our
antibody is specific
to certain epitope recognized by other
hybridoma clone or not
and thereby build your trust on our rear
clone
and the method that we follow here is
basically a blocking experiment
here in the explanation chart you can
see
that um in a regular staining of course
when the antibody
is conjugated to a fluorochrome and you
stain your cells
it shows you a hundred percent signal
in a competition essay we use pure
antibody of our affinity clone and we
stain the cells with this clone
uh to to completely block the epitope
now um now what happens
in this case then afterwards we perform
a staining with the fluorochrome
conjugated hybridoma antibody to see
if they can bind to antigen or not
in case the rear clone do not share the
same epitope as the hybridoma clone
this will result in a successful
staining in flow cytometry
here as you can see with no overlap
meaning that uh that the
hybridoma clone was basically targeting
another
um epitope in case the hybridoma clone
and the
affinity clone share the same epitope
the pure
antibody or the reaffinity antibody will
completely block the epitope thereby the
fluorochrome conjugated
hybridoma clone will not be able to bind
and you will not see any signal
and in the website we display this data
with
uh this kind of table so in our in our
product page where we have this kind of
data
you will be able to see compared to the
existing hybridoma
clone how our re-affinity clone is
performing in terms of their epitope
recognition
what is the benefit here for you you can
easily switch
from a clone that you are using before
um
as a hybridoma and you can find the
matching reaffinity clone
for your research and you can trust on
this because they are basically
recognizing the same epitope
and you can also compare the epidural
recognition of several clone at
address at a glance so this data
actually is valuable for you also to
to see the other clone performance
now the final uh part here is the
sensitivity of the
antibody and this basically means to
to check the performance of the antibody
product in different scenario to ensure
that they are sensitive enough for
different applications
and here well i will show you some of
the tests that we
performed to compare the antibody
sensitivity of our affinity clone
so of course the performance is tested
of the respective
application so i know i'm talking mainly
about the flow application but as i
mentioned we also test their performance
in
microscopy or mast cytometry when
applicable
further on we perform the performance of
the clone compared to the
alternative um hybridoma clone
and to to test their sensitivity and we
also display this data i will show you
in one slide later we also test the
performance upon fixation and also
performance in case of multi-parameter
flow cytometry panel
so quickly on the topic of the
performance comparison in flow analysis
here the aim is to demonstrate whether
the
performance of our affinity clone is
super superior or comparable
with the internet application or not
here basically we follow a method of
simple
um comparison of available clone
in the market and show how our affinity
is performing com
compared to the other clones in a comp
compatible flora com
conjugate and this kind of data set
will allow you to um also
perform less validation from your end as
well as give you the confidence about
the antibody quality
and such a data you can also access in
our product page
the the fixation actually is a very
important topic
as i can imagine a lot of you perform
experiments
uh on cells that are already fixed fixed
or you have to perform certain
fixation step and you need to make sure
that the antibody will perform
well in such a six six cells here we
perform um a staining of our antibodies
in before and after fixation with
formaldehyde
and in a typical case scenario when we
have the data available you
you can easily find them in the product
page um
and you can see the performance of this
particular clone here in cdc
riya 613 before and after fixation
of cells and this again
offer you the less validation effort as
well as support you
with a decision that whether this
is the right antibody for you to test or
not
finally the performance of the multiple
metal flow cytometry this is something
new that we are
trying to investigate because a lot of
this kind of antibodies of course
in the end are used in a multi-parameter
flow panel
and um here of course we um
test multiple antibodies together in a
panel
and we are trying to build this
collection uh collection of panels
that we call as the biotech tested panel
and we basically show the performance of
the panel
um here is a b cell panel data i'm
showing you
and we also offer the staining protocol
and the detail composition of the
antibody panel why certain marker was
used and
conjugated to which which and so on
and this kind of data of course also not
only reduces your validation effort
it also supports you with your basic
panel concept if you are
trying to start a new pro panel building
and so on
so um together with all these validation
data
we are trying to offer you the extended
validation
of the selected clone that um
are very important and necessary for you
to
make sure that the performance is um
is is right and as i mentioned
all these data that i have shown you
before
actually exist in our product page
website with a
um stamp that called as extended
validation and specifically the knockout
data performance comparison and the
fixation data
as well as the epidural competition
finally
additional documentation support we also
offer in the product page
where we show the tested application and
customer review reference and reagent
repository id and so on
now in the very final few minutes
i would like to discuss some of the
final consideration
um for um this whole topic of
reproducibility crisis and what is still
need to be
done from us and also you as a scientist
with the awareness of the
reproducibility reproducibility crisis
more and more scientific scientific
organizations
are requiring thorough documentation of
research using regions such as nih for
their grant application as well as the
big journals
nature cell and they request you to
submit
a really thorough um documentation
about the protocol of research region
of course as i already um discussed
throughout my
talk melting about it is trying uh its
best to
uh create transparency among customers
about our product
by providing detailed information
additional certificates
extended efforts of pre-tested panel
and more moreover a support
to our customer with all necessary
information through our experience
customer service and support
in addition we also ensure to actively
take part in
supporting scientific community with
this kind of quest for
antibody validation and here some of the
example of our past
participation in the antibody validation
meeting and the initiative from gbsi
as well as of course we're constantly
publishing a lot of
paper where our antibodies are used
now one of the final slide i would also
like to highlight what you
as a scientist can do to strongly
contribute
uh with this um reproducibility crisis
by testing and reporting the antibody
performance in your experiment
and including the detailed protocol in
their respective journal
use rrid and search engine
engines like antibody pedia and site app
and finally use
also high quality recombinant antibody
for your specific application
and here with my last slide i would like
to highlight that with highly validated
and recombinantly generated antibodies
you do not need to
throw away your precious data rather
you can build confident and reproducible
results
and with this i would like to thank you
for your attention
and i would be very happy to take any
further question you might have
thank you dr roy for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
is
is it possible to use this technique
with saliva
thanks for your question i hope you hear
me
so um you mean uh saliva
so there so our antibodies of course are
targeted for
uh markers that are expressed in uh
certain cell population
mainly so if there are um certain cell
population that you are interested in
within saliva sample
um i mean we haven't really tested
with such a specific sample type but um
i believe if there are cell types that
exist for which we have markers it
it may work
yeah thank you dr roy our next question
is
how many miltoni tested panels are out
there
um so um so it's probably referring to
the
the tested panel collection that i was
showing previously
so we just like i mentioned during the
presentation we just started with this
project
our aim is basically to test as more and
more
uh panel that are possible
that covers different types of cells
immune cells
and also other cell types
from primary origin so far we have
tested
around about 34 panels
but we aim to test more and
include more species um
and yeah also like i said different
sample origin
from different different tissue and and
so on
so yeah thank you dr roy
our next question looks like a two-part
question is it correct that only one
isotype control is enough for
re-affinity antibodies
and how about before fluorochrome
controls
yeah that's it that's a good question um
we also sometimes get this question very
often
from our customer um as i showed you
that the
the antibody was built on um human igg-1
isotype
so if you if your panel consists
of uh markers that
are um just in one fluorochrome
which of course is not always the case
uh
in that case of course you use uh the
same isotype if you have multiple
fluorochrome obviously because the
conjugate will perform differently
in that case one has to include the
multiple
fluorochrome but this
this um reduces the inventory management
in the
in the sense that in your bucket of all
antibody panel all you need to have just
a few different fruit chrome conjugated
to this
rare backbone that we call this human
igd-1
so if you have that that should cover
your all the panels that you
usually test
thank you dr roy
our next question is um does
fc receptor mutation in re-affinity
antibodies um abolish
all background noise um
so it's specifically to the fc gamma
receptor um
so the the mutation that we have
we have uh introduced within this fc
region
uh it's particularly targeted with this
unspecific
binding to the fc gamma receptor the
versions that i have shown you in one of
the
um data example um the aim is basically
to
um to kind of
just block this kind of binding that are
originating for this
fc gamma receptor one and two a and to
be
in those family those super family
because these are coming from um
uh mainly from the larger cell types
monocyte
so sometimes this background gives you
like false positive
um you may have background that are
originated from
dirty samples and um like
sample that you are working with your
gut
from the gut origin or origin which
contains some debris and stuff
that uh i'm i think it's
it's not going to work for these kind of
samples so
um when it comes to the specifically
this kind of
background that you expect to come from
fc
gamma origin there obviously this will
work
um i hope that answers
yeah thank you dr roy and our next
question here
um this person says to my understanding
this is not because one did not detect
an antigen that is not present how do
you make sure
that they are the protein is not present
do you use an alternative technique like
mass spec or other antibodies
um let me get it one more time so
one did not um antigen that it is not
present
how do you make sure there are pro that
the protein is not present
um so i i
if i understand correctly you were
referring to the knockout
data that we showed so
in specific uh for the knockout
generation i mean
we have a rnd team that is really
screening a lot of cell line to to
generate this kind of knockout
cells and they basically screen the cell
which expresses this protein
and then take those cells and
target the specific um region uh
which is responsible for this protein
expression and specifically mutate that
via
crispr cast system i have to check back
if they perform any
specific tests to confirm if this is
uh completely knocked out or not but
i remember at least when the rnd team
explained that to me
that this is the case so and of course
then we show this
via microscopy data as well as this um
flow cytometry test um to confirm that
it was the protein is completely um
abolished when when
yeah checked fire antibody binding yeah
oh thank you dr roy if you have further
questions please get back uh
get into touch with us i mean if you
have very specific questions i mean i'm
sure
we can get some information from our rnd
into another rnd
team yeah
great thank you i'm sure people
appreciate that being able to get a
little bit more specific
and probably easier to do that on email
sometimes okay so the next question
do you have extended validation data for
all re-affinity antibodies
um so
that's a fair question i mean of course
as you can imagine all this test takes a
huge amount of effort
um and um
we are obviously trying our best to to
keep up with as much as possible
um to to add more data for all the
antibodies but at the moment we don't
have for all our antibodies
but i believe we have already more than
300 clones for which we have done this
extended validation
and this project is continuing and we
yeah we definitely would like to
continue this and
prove the validity of our antibody as
much as possible with this kind of data
set
yes
thank you dr roy oh so we have another
question uh
similar to the last question from the
same person so the same question applies
to specif
but applied to specificity competition
assay
so he says this is not because the
signal is low uh
then the epitope is not present the
antibody may not
have access to the epitope for some
other reason did you try targeted
mutations in the epitope
ala scan for instance to assess
specificity
um that's a good point i mean honestly
with the easy answer no i we haven't
done some such a extensive
level to to special targeting
yeah do some targeted mutations
um yeah as i explained i mean
you you are right i mean there can be
definitely other effect
but um in principle um this
we have actually followed some of the
tests that uh
have been uh explained in the field uh
for yeah for testing this kind of
epidural binding uh in in that regard so
we just followed these essays but this
is the feedback i can definitely bring
bring back with me and discuss with our
team
and see if if there is any additional
essay they could perform to confirm that
there is no any other additional effect
on the competition
uh on the competition essay in that
sense
thanks for the question though thank you
dr roy
and we've got one last question uh
finally are you able to produce in gmp
environment
yeah so um yeah currently um with
gmp environment i mean we still have um
some use of some serum in the production
system so it cannot be completely
produced in a dmp environment but
the rnd is um
trying with uh with that to bring the
recombinant technology within the gmp
environment and
yeah i can only say hopefully
uh we'll see some of our antibodies um
and be able to offer them in a gnp
condition
in in in the future yeah
thank you dr roy do you have any final
comments for our audience today
yeah um so thanks again uh for
taking part in all your questions uh i
mean
i hope i could um yeah
bring back the extensive effort that uh
within the team
that are trying to to uh to perform to
validate our antibiotics on so if you
have any further feedback
and you are interested to learn more or
want to
uh yeah want to get any additional
information
please feel free to reach out via email
uh yeah i would be very happy to to give
you
further feedback if possible
that's all thank you again dr roy for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye